vous êtes et puis honnêtement dîner bon
patron à une proposition à vous faire
j'ai fait fortune en fait à
vous vous doutez bien qu avez-vous tout
ça je n'ai pas vraiment eu le temps de
fonder une famille j'aimerais essayer
alors qu'on est ici quoi ils famille si
une famille ben parce que je vous
propose
j'ai poncho dette je vous donne
l'équivalent d'un an de salaire et en
retour vous me prenez dans votre fric
wen a stoppé leurs primes aux
interdictions de dire quoi que ce soit
aux enfants pauvres dans mon monde à moi
l'amour ça s'achète pas souri ce que je
veux dire alors l'argent de poche 200
euros par semaine pas un centime de plus
me paraît tout à fait garde pour
l'argent de poche au vert à pita deuxio
on leur fait croire que c'est un coup de
foudre tout
vous trouvez j'ai souvent des coups de
fautes qui sont eux mêmes pris de court
tous différents oui largement disparu de
la circulation et des coûts tout comme
un troisième sur steam usines que moi
couchent ensemble
non non non non non j'essaye une famille
mes potes